surgery for thyroid cancer requires the
removal of the whole thyroid gland there
are four very small parathyroid glands
that sit next to the thyroid and
sometimes during this operation
they are inadvertently injured or
removed when that happens patients
develop what is called
hypoparathyroidism that results in
disruption of calcium metabolism
specifically low calcium levels when
patients develop low calcium levels they
have symptoms tingling numbness
irregular heartbeats and they must seek
urgent medical attention to treat it
they have to take calcium and vitamin D
supplements between four and six times a
day
our research using human embryonic as
stem cells is intended to create an
alternative for patients so that they
don't have to take calcium and vitamin D
supplements around the clock what we
ultimately would like to do is to use
patient's own cells to create
parathyroid cells and implant them into
some part of their body any muscle that
has blood supply where it can grow and
manufacture calcium thereby removing the
need to take the medicine I think they
would be afforded a significant
improvement in the overall quality of
their life
there's a reason why there's only one
other group in the world doing this kind
of research and that is that working
with stem cells is hard work in fact
it's seven days a week work these cells
are slow growing and they're very
finicky so they require a great deal of
attention
going has been slow but already we've
started to have results as we drive stem
cells toward becoming parathyroid cells
we check for specific genetic markers
that we have gotten this far in the
pathway these markers are now turning on
for us suggesting we're well on our way
to the creation of parathyroid cells
from stem cells
with the monies provided by Women's
Health Research we've been able to
obtain pilot data which has allowed us
to apply for additional funding from the
state of Connecticut as well as funding
from generous private donors with a
special interest in thyroid and
parathyroid disease
women's health research is willing to
take a chance on good ideas and good
scientists and it really gave us this
unique opportunity to pursue an
interesting question that I think
without the pilot funds we received
would have been impossible